[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 3 février début d'une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 60,18 bienvenue dans ce journal
voici les titres un week-end dédié sport
féminin toujours pour plus d'égalité
lutter contre les discriminations à
cette occasion le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillait
une journée autour du cyclisme samedi la
ministre des sports roxana maracineanu
étaient présentes
cet événement aura lieu en septembre
prochain le festival pulsations et bien
confirmé à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines la convention de ce
rendez vous artistique et solidaire a
été signé ce matin et une avant première
ce soir au ciné cet élan courcelles de
la dernière vie de simon d'histoires
fantastiques d'un enfant cherchant une
famille il s'agit du premier long
métrage de léo karman jeune réalisateur
de maurepas passé par l'école troisième
et puis ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité sportive du week-end à
suivre dans cette édition
mais d'abord j'accueille ma première
invitée c'est martha de sea dragon soir
dans ça vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains des yvelines alors on parle
avec vous de ce texte qui vient d'être
adoptée au parlement ultime vote au
sénat qui a eu lieu jeudi dernier c'est
la loi anti gaspillage pour une économie
solidaire circulaire circulaire on
précise bien aussi mais c'est peut-être
aussi l'objectif de ce texte
vous avez porté ce texte martha décidera
quand en étant l'un des rapporteurs au
sénat déjà de voir aboutir cette loi
après plusieurs navettes parlementaires
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça vous
fait alors écoutez une réelle
satisfaction il reste six actions pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que dès
le début au sénat nous nous sommes
attelés à ce texte avec beaucoup
beaucoup de rigueur de sérieux et puis
j'ai presque envie d'ailleurs de
patients par moment et aussi parce que
la deuxième raison c'est que beaucoup
annoncent et une commission mixte
paritaire non conclusives or elle a été
conclue ziv et non seulement conclusive
les conclusive à l'unanimité cela
signifie que à un moment donné lorsque
le texte a été examiné à la fois chez
nous à la fois à l'assemblée
sénateurs et députés se sont réunis au
sein de la commission mixte paritaire et
nous l'avons voté complètement tous
ensemble avec aucune voix qui de
discordance à au moment du vote et donc
ça je crois que c'est un message fort ça
veut dire que la volonté du sénat
puisque nous l'avons énormément amendé
j'ai beaucoup portée de certaines
modifications certain enrichissement
avec mes collègues sénateurs et cela n'a
pas été détricoté et oui aujourd'hui
nous sommes à la fois soulagé à la fois
satisfait oui on peut parler d'une
petite révolution avec ceux des
révolutions non parce qu'il faut rester
modeste et humble en matière
d'environnement beaucoup de choses
restent à faire devant nous mais je
crois que grâce à ce texte là un certain
nombre de jalons et d'exigence sont
clairement posée et on ne pourra pas
dire bon bah écoutez on savait pas on
sait pas trop quoi en faire là
maintenant il ya des choses et des voix
qui ont été ouvertes
ben nous maintenant de les faire
prospérer et je dirais d'aller peut-être
un peu plus loin par la suite en effet
on va détailler les objectifs dans un
instant ce qu'elle va changer
concrètement dans le quotidien des
français
cette loi alors ça ne se verra pas
forcément automatiquement
en revanche vous avez dû déjà le voir
d'ailleurs ne serait ce que dans les
publicités aujourd'hui que l'on voit
dans les médias à la télévision on parle
maintenant beaucoup d'économie
circulaire de plus tôt réparer que de
jeter
donc on voit quand même que le message
commence à passer puisque c'est
exactement ce type de choses est de
disposer de dispositions que nous avons
introduit dans la loi et donc ça c'est
quelque chose quand même qui est assez
positif vis-à-vis du consommateur mais
nous avons tout un volet qui est
véritablement à destination de des
consommateurs que nous sommes vous et
moir et
nous permettront d'avoir un peu plus un
regard je dirais responsable et puis en
connaissance de cause lorsqu'on achète
un objet on saura si on peut le réparer
par le réparer at il été fait avec des
matériaux recyclés ou pas et donc à
partir de là on ne pourra pas dire ah
bah écoutez moi j'ai acheté un truc en
plastique je pensais que c'était
vertueuse jusqu'à non qu'est-ce que vous
aurez toutes les informations
vous ne pourrez pas dire je ne savais
pas on peut voir par exemple dans les
fast food en les premiers contenants en
plastique disparaître peut être un
premier pas qui va s'accompagner de
d'autres dans cette loi cinq grands
objectifs notamment sortir du plastique
jetables avec cet objectif qui est fixé
d'ici à 2040 de faire du zéro plastique
jetables est-ce que c'est atteignable
alors oui oui je pense que c'est
atteignable et je crois que les
industriels contrairement à ce qu'on
peut entendre aussi ici et là on nous
parfaitement conscience donc on le voit
bien mois dans les entretiens dans les
échanges dans les auditions que j'ai pu
avoir cette prise de conscience existe
du côté des industriels
la question qui se pose à nous c'est à
quelle vitesse il ya les 2040 vous vous
souvenez lorsque le cela a été voté donc
à l'assemblée puis chez nous en fait
ceux de 1040 apparu lointain pour
certains trop proche pour d'autres mais
je crois que c'est déjà bien d'avoir une
échéance parce que ça nous obligera à ce
que je vous disais en préambule
quand même d'avancer dans le bon sens et
tout ça ça passe aussi par un autre
objectif c'est l'un des autres objectifs
de cette loi de mieux informer les
consommateurs c'est vrai qu'on a on a du
mal à s'y retrouver sur ce qu'il faut
acheter ce qu'il faut trier mieux
informés ça c'était un objectif aussi
importants apportés dans cette nuit ce
que le texte initial comportait très
article aujourd'hui il en comportant 131
donc ça vous donne une idée un petit peu
de l'enrichissement de ce texte là pour
l'essentiel qui est le texte du sénat
puisqu'il est arrivé chez nous en
première lecture
donc de ce point de vue en tant que
sénatrice des yvelines vous comprenez
bien que je vois là je suis assez
satisfaite aujourd'hui
toutefois ce qui est importante
vis-à-vis du consommateur aussi c'est
que dans ce texte initialement il ne
s'intéressait qu'à l'aval c'est-à-dire
une fois que un objet que vous avez
acheté devenait déchets on essaie de le
recycler de stars annoncées beaucoup
intéressé aussi à l'amont c'est-à-dire
justement ce que vous évoquez a juste
dit la responsabilité du consommateur
puisque nous avons introduit à la fois
des fonds de réparabilité durabilité
nombre de dispositions de dispositifs et
de grands volets d'information du
consommateur et notamment autour du tri
informer aussi j'imagine parmi les plus
jeunes ça ça peut favoriser le moins
gaspiller le fait de moins gaspiller
aussi oui tout à fait moi je crois
beaucoup à notre jeunesse je crois
beaucoup à nos jeunes qui nous pousse 1
ce sont de véritables tireur d'ald
alerte 1 donc de ce point de vue c'est
important d'ailleurs moi j'ai décidé
cette année je vais aller m'inviter dans
les lycées les collèges pour essayer de
partager avec eux tout ce que ce texte
là peut apporter
mais j'ai presque envie de dire on peut
même aller plus loin vous voyez là
vraiment on a des bases très modestement
place mais qui sont très concrètes et
qui nous permettront d'aller plus loin
tous ensemble collectivement et ça j'y
crois beaucoup
alors dans les objectifs il ya mieux
produire je voulais évoquer un dernier
objectif il nous reste une minute dans
cet entretien c'est de lutter aussi
d'agir contre l'obsolescence programmée
on sait qu'un foyer français en moyenne
99 appareils électriques ou
électroniques chez lui plus d'un million
de tonnes de ces appareils sont jetés
chaque année il est aussi quelque chose
à faire sur sur ce point de vue là oui
tout à fait et donc ça a été introduit
c'était déjà dans la feuille de route de
l'économie circulaire
donc la loi a permis de justement
préciser un certain nombre de choses
autour de cette obsolescence qui comme
vous le dites est un véritable fléau
et puis aussi de pouvoir réparer parfois
des objets que l'eau jour d'hui on a
tendance à jeter pour acheter du neuf
parce qu'on se dit finalement ça me
revient presque moins cher ne rachetait
du neuf
or maintenant on va pouvoir sur un
certain nombre de nouveaux objets les
réparer avec le fonds de solidarité ça
nous permettra d'envoyer de la
solidarité dans le texte ça nous
permettra de compenser en fait l'écart
de prix qui peut y avoir entre achat
neuf et réparation merci martin est
repassé en plateau sénatrice les
républicains des yvelines rapporteur du
texte sur la loi anti gaspillage pour
une économie circulaire et ce texte un
choc précise qui vient d'être tout juste
adoptée définitivement dans la page
politique les élections municipales
premier tour au programme le 15 mars
prochain emploi réussite scolaire
sécurité voici les thèmes abordés à
l'occasion du lancement
deux campagnes de la candidature
engagement trappe citoyens vendredi elle
est menée par un duo ou othman nasri
comme tête de liste et mustapha larbaoui
le reportage de mélanie poké de manon
varaldo engagement trappe citoyens liste
d'union locales menées par mustapha
larbaoui avec comme tête de liste
othman nasri présentent leur campagne
avec un programme autour de dix
engagements parmi eux la réussite
scolaire je défends la même idée le
retour à la semaine de quatre jours où
le front avec les parents d'élèves dont
on a toujours été solidaire il faut 4 ap
on est les mêmes chances de réussir
tailleur autre préoccupation la n 10 qui
coupent cette ville et le bruit routier
auquel plus de 8% des trappistes sont
exposés le candidat trouvent que le
projet d'enfouissement de la n10 n'est
pas aboutie je propose aussi de faire
évoluer ce projet par exemple avec d
enrobé phonique sur la nationale 10 là
aussi la région ile de france sur
laquelle je siège à financer des projets
de ce type là le timbre à l'haÿ les
roses et les résultats sont extrêmement
bon on divise de bruit par quatre parmi
ses autres propositions la création
d'une police de proximité au service des
habitants 24 heures sur 24
actuellement il existe une police
municipale composée seulement de huit
agents qui ne fonctionnent que la
journée j'ai l'intention ferme de ma
part renforcer la police municipale
triple rares ses effectifs pour qu'on
arrive à une police municipale de 30
agents et puis nous renforcerons la
vidéo protection autour notamment des
écoles et des commerces batman n'a
through élu vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement économique depuis 2010 9
souhaite baisser le taux de chômage à
trappes qui est de 19% contre 12% sur
saint quentin en yvelines
la proposition que je fais aujourd'hui
sur la question de l'emploi est simple
c'est de proposer aux trappistes mille
formation professionnelle qualifiante
qui débouche sur des armes pour des
emplois des formations de courte durée
dans les métiers en tension le programme
de la liste engagement trappe citoyen
est aussi présentée dans un livret de
trente et une page direction magny les
hameaux à présent pour connaître les
enjeux des municipales dans la commune
désenclavement problèmes de circulation
ou encore potentiel agricole ont fait le
point avec mélanie poké à cheval sur le
parc naturel de la haute vallée de
chevreuse et l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines magny les hameaux à
une double identité rurale et urbaine
une commune de 9000 491 habitants
répartis en sept hameaux et sur 16
kilomètres carrés un isolement
géographique qui pourrait s'améliorer
grâce à l'augmentation de lignes de bus
ou le développement de pistes cyclables
pour quitter ou accéder à magny les
hameaux de route départementale qui pose
problème la 91 passant par voisins le
bretonneux rapidement encombrer en
heures de pointe est source de conflit
entre les deux communes en octobre 2018
côté château fort la 938 est tout aussi
impactés a été envisagé un temps la
réouverture du chemin vicinal 7 fermer
en octobre 2001 nicolas abou maire de
montigny le bretonneux
après la fermeture des jardins de
cocagne en 2015 la question du passé
agricole de la commune s'est posée la
ferme de bulot y est destiné dans un
premier temps à être vendus ne le sera
finalement pas saint quentin en yvelines
a donné son accord en 2019
un projet de pérennisation agricole de
formation de tourisme et d'insertion est
en cours la ferme de gomberville a été
acheté à sa propriétaire par
l'agglomération celle de la closeraie
accueillera bientôt une chaîne de
transformation de l'aisne de marché de
magny les hameaux est un souhait de
nombreux habitants marché couvert où
marché de plein-vent le projet pour le
moment au point mort
un appel lancé auprès de prestataires
franciliens en 2018 s'est soldée par un
échec
une nouvelle tentative a été lancé
auprès des commerçants en juillet 2019
et sa place fait aussi débat
et d'ailleurs si ce n'est pas le cas
vous avez encore jeu quelques jours pour
vous inscrire sur les listes électorales
date fixée à vendredi la date limite est
fixée à vendredi sont concernés
notamment les personnes ayant déménagé
récemment dans une autre commune
inscriptions à faire soit directement en
mairie soit sur internet
www.servigardes.fr il vous faudra vous
munir d'une pièce d'identité en cours de
validité et d'un justificatif de
domicile
il a choisi le dernier jour du mois de
janvier pour souhaiter ses voeux à
villepreux le maire stéphane mirambeau
conduisait la cérémonie vendredi dernier
au gymnase alain
moon et l'élu en a profité pour mettre à
l'honneur une conseillère municipale
pour son engagement dans la commune
depuis de nombreuses années le premier
magistrat de la ville est également
revenu sur les grands projets menés ou
entamé en 2010 9,7 au micro d'aurélie
ans il ya eu la livraison au début de
l'année du gymnase des zones du moulin
et il ya un sujet qui est vraiment le
plus important c'est la construction
d'écoles le groupe scolaire est vraiment
attendu dans les quartiers de cris dodge
on a eu un an de retard vu qu'il ya eu
des soucis sur les sûr avec certaines
entreprises là il ya une énorme attente
les gens veulent absolument que le
groupe scolaire ouvre pour le mois de
septembre
c'est une attente vraiment extrêmement
forte et je suis ravi on a tout donné et
le groupe scolaire ouvrira bien en
septembre prochain pour les enfants de
ce nouveau quartier autres cérémonies de
voeux vendredi celle de ce lait veut
c'est la cérémonie de voeux de des voeux
par bourg de la dixième de la députée de
la 10e circonscription des yvelines
aurore bergé je vais y arriver c'était à
coignières plus de 150 personnes réunies
en intersyndicale ont profité de la
présence de la parlementaire porte
parole de la république en marche pour
faire entendre leur voix
opposition au projet de réforme des
retraites examiné à l'assemblée
nationale à partir du 17 février les
manifestants rejoints par une trentaine
de gilet jaune ont bloqué la nationale
10 pendant quelques minutes avant d'être
délogés par la police sans incident
[Musique]
l'actualité du jour c'est la signature
de cette convention ce lundi matin le
festival pulsations pensé par anima sera
bel et bien organisé à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines en
septembre à la convention entre
l'association et la direction du lieu a
été signé ce matin à nîmes asos doit
maintenant réfléchir au point technique
et financier avant de recevoir ses
festivaliers à la rentrée de 2020
mathilde et demi c'est maintenant acté
le festival pulsations sont organisées à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines le 26 et 27 septembre 2020
l'heure est maintenant à la réflexion
pour trouver des partenaires mais aussi
des artistes pour créer la programmation
l'idée maintenant c'est donc d'aller
construire complètement festival donc
terminée la programmation musicale
préparer tous les aspects techniques
logistiques sécuritaire évidemment du
site pour que le festival puisse se
tenir dans les meilleures dispositions
pendant les deux journées du 26 et 27
une plus value pour lille de loisirs qui
accueillera les festivaliers fin
septembre suite à la signature de la
convention
elle montre notre volonté de développer
sur sa télé loisirs les opérations
culturelles pour le grand public
réfléchir aux contraintes de la météo
respecter le milieu environnemental du
parc ou mettre en place un système de
sécurité
ce sont les points techniques encore
avoir avant que le festival pulsations
ne s'installe à saint quentin en
yvelines
on parle d'un film à présent qui sera en
salles ce mercredi la dernière vie de
simon essais réalisés par vous les eaux
karman bonsoir vous êtes passé par trois
yes l'institut international de l'image
et du son ont basé à elancourt vous êtes
originaire de maurepas et vous présentez
votre fils ce soit en avant-première au
ciné cette île en cours c'est à 20h30
bonsoir le bloquant bonsoir d'être le
directeur du cinéma antiputsch déjà pour
commencer c'est l'histoire de simon
huit ans qui est orphelin et qui rêve
d'avoir une famille et simon a un
pouvoir particulier il peut prendre
l'apparence de toutes les personnes qui
l'ont touché je m'arrête là pour le
pitch que lui lui a touché en tous les
cas que lui a touché
on s'arrête là pour le pied et pour se
faire une idée on peut le gardent tout
de suite un extrait de la bande annonce
ce que je vais vous montrer je vais
montrer à personne c'est quoi ils font
promettre qui après ça je deviendrai
matin deux sens même si vous trouvez çà
bizare
vous prenez
encre rouge
[Musique]
voilà
voilà pour cet extrait l'eau 40 pourquoi
raconter cette histoire celle de sept
orphelins qui a ce pouvoir particulier
en fait avec sabrina baccarin la
coscénariste du film on avait envie de
faire un cinéma qui ressemble au cinéma
qu lequel on agrandit quoi le cinéma les
années 90 américain spielberg cameron
zem qui ce cinéma on passe deux heures
dans la salle à rêver à passer par plein
d'émotion à des émotions ventre et puis
c'est des histoires qui font l'histoire
de l'autre voisin de siège continent des
histoires un peu extraordinaire puis
quand on sort de la salle après on
réalise que c'est en plus une histoire
qui nous parle de notre vie et on se dit
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire comme
histoire qui plus est dans ce genre de
cinéma mais faisable en premier film en
france et voilà et on a eu l'idée de
ceux de ce garçon qui avait ce pouvoir
particulier il faisait plusieurs acteurs
qui vous même le rôle et ça peut être
trop cher quoi et vous parlez de
spielberg l'écran fantastique a dit
justement du film que spielberg à de
nouveaux cousins français en parlant de
votre film quand on entend ça est-ce
qu'on est fiers hausse qu'on est
paniquée à l'idée de d'abord cet
héritage d'héritage de spielberg
quand on est maman fière 1 évidemment
hyper content d'avoir cette comparaison
incroyable après c'est pas nous qui la
faisons c'est eux et on est ravi que ça
leur plaise d'en bas tout comme c'était
vraiment la référence et que c'est le
cinéma que lequel on a grandi on est
ravis d'en être content d'y être
comparées entre les a bien sûr lui
procure est ce que vous avez vu le film
oui nous avions n'ai pensé à nous j'aime
énormément et je le disais à léo en
attendant tout alors on vous attend dans
sang occulte flagornerie vraiment c'est
un très très beau film c'est un premier
long métrage comme léo vient de le dire
c'est impressionnant comme de virtuosité
et l'histoire est très très forte gelée
vu avec mes collègues je me souviens à
l'époque où le film était pas encore
feeling et il n'y avait pas de générique
de fin
du ma mémoire est bonne et c'est vrai
qu'on est resté scotché on est sorti de
la projection on était tous d'ailleurs
on était assez nombreux il y avait ton
père ta mère là aussi je me suis très
bien et on était tous vraiment
e
très très très très agréablement surpris
c'est un très très beau film et de la
voir en avant-première c'était important
pour le dîner c'est oui bien sûr alors
ça c'est le compagnonnage
on va dire presque la famille avec avec
la famille karmann avec catherine je
suis dès alleo catherine olsson qui qui
joue et qui chantait du jazz en ré
festival polar il ya 10-15 un an au
prisme
c'est la rencontre avec sam que je
connais depuis longtemps aussi qui a
toujours été là pour nous soutenir pour
nous aider avec catherine si voilà il a
toujours répondu présent chaque fois je
vais inviter il est venu avec son
caractère avec ce qu'il a à dire avec sa
franchise que j'aime beaucoup
voilà et puis maintenant c'est léo donc
les au premier long métrage au qui nous
paraissaient ils me font qu'elle veut
paraissait absolument naturel de
soutenir ce film et c'est d'autant plus
agréable de soutenir qu'il est très bon
et justement le fait de le présenter en
avant-première à elancourt le lieu où
vous avez étudié
vous êtes passé par l'école troisième
vous êtes aussi originaire de maurepas
est-ce que ça ça vous tenait à coeur ça
revêt un caractère particulier si ce
n'est évidemment plus même c'est le
cinéma dans lequel j'allais avant même
d'être étudiant à troisième quoi c'est
le cinéma de tous mais de toutes les
émotions de cinéphiles que je me
souviens de la file d'attenté
interminable pour les voir harry potter
c'était aussi né cet été c'était mes
premiers souvenirs de cinéma de magie
quoi si on revient sur le projet du film
je crois que ça a pris 9 ans de l'idée
jusqu'à l'aboutissement pourquoi cela a
pris autant de temps on aime bien dire
que les enfants deux filles n'étaient
pas nés quand on a eu l'idée
samedi temps parce qu'en fait on
on nous a dit qu'on faisait passer en
france on fait passer en france le
cinéma l'imaginaire c'est pas pour nous
c'est pour les américains les anglais
des asiatiques voilà alors quand je sais
quand même dans notre culture je dire
jules verne cocteau enfin c'est quand
même notre culture l'imaginaire mais
j'aimerais soit genre bah oui parce que
je ne sais pas à quel moment où on dit
que les français n'étaient pas capables
de faire ça et on va nous a même dit le
scénario est extraordinaire on leur
effet ces deux réacteurs étaient coréen
on doit sortir des choses comme ça quand
on les donne le film donc ça a mis
beaucoup de temps se met beaucoup de
temps de convaincre qu'on était capable
et surtout que le public français avait
envie de voir ça le goût pour le cinéma
d'où vient-il on nous parlait du papa
forcément sam karmann ce que ça vient de
là le logo sera basée sûr que le grandia
abbas et surtout de grandir dans une
famille qui est quand même les au cinéma
ça aide
après j'aime je crois j'ai envie de
faire du cinéma en tout cas de raconter
des histoires depuis depuis tout petits
du vivant je crois qu'ils avaient huit
ans quand j'ai découvert cook de steven
spielberg israël le film va donner envie
de faire du cinéma parce que c'est
incroyable ce film c'est un truc où on a
un pacte entre le réalisateur et les
spectateurs gens vous savez qui est des
corses le carton pas vous savez que tout
ce que vous voyez est faux mais on va y
croire ensemble et c'est vraiment ce que
j'ai adoré dans ce film et ce qui pour
moi la définition du cinéma que que
j'aime
alors après avoir des parents dans le
cinéma ce qui est formidable c'est que
quand vous leur dites que vous voulez en
faire il vous regarde pas trop bizarre
couleurs douces et des bonnes nouvelles
il a de quoi vous parlez quoi voilà ça
c'est le veut une dernière chose sur
l'objectif on précise que le film a reçu
déjà trois distinctions trois prix du
public au festival d'automne de gardanne
mon premier festival est aussi au
festival de brides-les-bains l'objectif
maintenant pour le film il va sortir
l'art mercredi en salles puisqu'il sait
que le maximum de personnes en profitent
c'est à dire que on est hyper content on
a un accueil pour l'instant public au
festival qui est formidable
on accueille presque est très bon
maintenant il faut que c'est toujours
c'est ce qui est compliqué avec ce genre
de film ce qui a pas de stars mais c'est
ce qu'on nous a dit pendant tout
financement du film n'y a pas de stars
pour aller à la télévision pour en
parler du film pour amener les des
familles au cinéma donc en fait c'est de
prendre le pari que l'histoire le genre
ce qu'on en dit suffisamment teese et la
curiosité et que les gens se déplacent
même sans connaître personne à la fiche
avant première de la dernière vie de
simon ce soir au ciné cet élan course et
à 20h30 et ce qu'il reste des places
il en reste l'essai réalisé par voulait
au carbone merci d'être passé en place à
lubbock ans directeur du ciné 7
d'elancourt
le sport maintenant avec cet événement
dont je vous parlais dans les titres ce
week-end était dédiée au sport féminin
une opération du ministère des sports et
du conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
pour plus de visibilité et d'égalité le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines et la fédération française de
cyclisme ont pris part à l'événement
samedi lancement d'une opération vivre
vélo au féminin mélanie poké et marylène
iapichino pour les détails une piste
100% féminine pour cette journée dédiée
la ministre des sports était même au
rendez-vous pour promouvoir la pratique
des femmes que ce soit en compétition ou
en loisir objectif principal prendre du
plaisir
arrivé à parler plus de progrès plus de
plaisir que de sacrifices au nom de la
performance c'est notre objectif au
ministère des sports
aujourd'hui c'est important de dire
qu'aussi bien
la performance des femmes que celle des
hommes méritent d'être plus médiatisé
plus mise à l'antenne
[Musique]
seuls 10% de ses licenciés sont des
femmes alors la fédération française de
cyclisme s'est saisie de cette opération
pour lancer son programme vivre vélo au
féminin il faut travailler sur ses
points faibles
ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on structure
vraiment notre taux de féminisation
qu'on commence à mettre en place à
pouvoir mettre en place des actions de
fond comme celle qu'on présente
aujourd'hui et j'espère que les fruits
de la croissance est bien on va les
trouver dans les prochaines années
pour cela la fédération a mis en place
un réseau d'ambassadrices dans toute la
france chargée d'organiser des
événements et d'encourager le cyclisme
féminin
je pense que les les femmes qui n'est
pas vraiment envie de faire du vélo
peut-être manque d'encadrement ou de
motivation d'être dans un groupe de
femmes donc voilà c'est à nous
maintenant de mettre en place des choses
à travers ce beau projet pour leur
donner envie de faire du vélo avec nous
dans la vallée de chevreuse
toute la journée les femmes étaient
invités à s'essayer au cyclisme sur
piste pour pourquoi pas s'inscrire en
club et faire progresser les chiffres
féminin
[Musique]
et pour terminer ce journal on fait le
point sur les résultats sportifs du
week-end dans les yvelines avec michael
et demi d'euros bonsoir on s'engueulait
analystes aux sports de la rédaction de
tv 78 du handball pour commencer
michiels avec le championnat honneur
régional trappe pg c'est l affiche de
cette 14e journée du championnat honneur
régional ce samedi 1er février dans une
salle bouillante chauffée par des
centaines de supporters les trappistes
entre dans la partie de la meilleure des
façons en prenant le large rapidement le
score à la pause 18 8e rang avec 10
points parce qu'on a mis beaucoup
d'intensité beaucoup beaucoup de lui
[Musique]
on a aussi remonté les balles poser nojy
les attaques dont celui de la patience
on a récité notre meilleur handball
cette première mi temps
largement au retour des vestiaires les
trappistes reste devant mais connaissent
un passage à vide après la blessure d'un
joueur de l'équipe 15 minutes
d'interruption au total le psg tente de
revenir après ce fait de jeu mais n'y
arrivera finalement pas ce qu'en finale
33 à 25 mai les trappistes dans ce match
accroché réaction a été compliqué c'est
vrai on rencontre une équipe commune du
mazet qui a été traqué qui équilibre etc
et reste libre était qu'à l'habitude de
jouer des matches difficiles
ils sont d'ailleurs partis la semaine
dernière ils étaient préparés ils ont
battu l'équipe tt première ex-aequo avec
nous et du coup c'était un match
compliqué à aborder à préparer et mais
on a réussi quand même à rester
régulier et consorts commencement
thouars au classement trappe reste
leader avec deux points d'avancé sur val
d'europe prochain match pour les attrape
east le samedi 29 février sur le terrain
de montfermeil quatrième du classement
une victoire permettra à trappes
d'envisager une sixième montée
consécutive en cinq ans on continue par
du football en football ont joué dans le
championnat de première division de
district voisin fait match nul contre
gargenville un partout le chesnay
s'incline contre hardricourt 3-0 mort
parce s'offre un festival offensif
contre sartrouville 6 un match nul entre
aubergenville et hull 3 partout careaga
ions s'offrent aux bois d'arcy 3 0 enfin
à bailly noisy gagne contre le pec 5 à 0
le championnat est dominé par maurepas
devant un gars gens monter en une part
du football mais cette fois-ci américain
de super bowl pour les templiers mais un
match de championnat de deuxième
division casque d'or les élans courtois
se sont imposés 23 à 13 contre les
myrmidon de savigny-le-temple au
classement ce résultat permet aux
templiers de se replacer la troisième
place de leur poule après deux matches
disputés et une défaite lors de leur
premier match est ainsi mickaël plus de
résultats à suivre dans un instant votre
émission le cetud sport voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]